look we need to move on because because
we have somebody who's actually doing
hard work
on this show and that's chris haynes
who's on the nba campus in orlando and
he's covering everything that comes and
goes and lately we've had players
doing exactly that because james harden
is now in orlando
we've gotten word that zion williamson
has left the campus
uh hoping to return at a later time
let's get
let's get all the stories behind these
with with chris
and um i guess let's start with james
harden because i know he
went through his first practice a short
time ago
yeah he went went through endured his
first practice here
with the houston rockets and i was told
that you know he looked good
i was told there wasn't much rust at all
but he had a chance to
to speak to the media via zoom and this
is what he had to say after practice
today
i feel like i'm in a good place uh today
was actually the first time that i
actually played pickup you know some 505
contact in
you know over a month uh individual
working out and conditioning is totally
different
you know it's uh you know you can do
track workouts you can do all different
type of conditioning workouts but
when you're actually out there you get
bumped and you got to actually make
plays and make reads and
get up and down the court um it's
totally different so it felt really good
today i think
i pushed myself through it today and
like i said every single day just
gotta continue to get better
now ernie as you mentioned about zion
williamson
well ernie as you mentioned by zion
williamson prior uh
he left the campus and it was because of
a medical reason with a family member
and he is the pelicans hope that he will
return
at some point before the restart but
they're not giving any timetable now
we'll say this
the nba is investigating the
circumstances
of this cause and once they determine
truly what that is
then they will know how long he has to
quarantine
when he once he comes returns back now
we do want to say about a player who is
not here
i mean what
well all right i want to talk about
player who that is not here right now
milwaukee bucks guard eric bledsoe he
has not been here
since the team arrived last week i spoke
to bledsoe and he told me the reason
he's not here
is that he he tested positive for the
covet 19.
he told me he's not feeling any symptoms
and he he's
he really really feels good and he is
hoping
that he will get here as soon as
possible as soon as he fulfills all the
nba's protocols
sorry for the delay and you know they
got the two-second delay here and i know
i'm kind of
you know ruining your flow from time to
time as i just try to
interrupt but let me talk to you about
zion now and this is
because this is kind of a complicated
thing in terms of
leaving the campus depending on how long
you're gone from the campus
and like negative tests while you're
away and that's going to help determine
how much time you'd have to be
quarantined when you get back
correct so we don't we don't know
exactly how this is going to impact
two weeks from tonight when the pelicans
are supposed to play the first game
that that we don't know and the pelicans
were sure
to not be able to put on a timeline so
we couldn't speculate moving forward but
i will say this if he is testing daily
and getting negative tests then he will
only have to quarantine
for four days before returning to the
bubble but we just don't know
the extent of how often he's going to
test while he's away
so there's a lot up in the air there's
definitely a lot up in the air as it
pertains
to that season opener in which they face
the jazz
chris haines thank you so much for uh
again uh
working on all the story angles down
there in orlando and keeping us up to
speed we uh
you know we got this countdown going two
weeks from tonight hopefully they're
playing basketball again that's chris
haynes
down there at the nba campus in orlando